let me say a little bit in terms of
introduction I'm going to start off the
course the first half of lecture then
dr. Clin is going to take over and I
want to acknowledge a couple of people
most importantly the filming which is
not totally free it's being supported by
several associates of the Child Study
Center which is fantastic we're also
very grateful to our colleagues who are
putting up with the hassle of creating
presentations that are going to
potentially go on the web there's
information on the website which you can
go to and once we get everything up and
running they'll be reading other kinds
of materials on that website every week
we're supposed to always say what our
conflicts of interests are both I and
dr. Clinton various federal grants and
book royalties I also edit the journal
of autism we're filming this week assure
her we went over the logistics next week
we'll be on the ground floor conference
room one of the things I've discovered
there's not a single adequate text I
tried to write a textbook a few years
ago for Cambridge University Press it's
a wonderful book it's paperback it's
part of a series it's $80 for a
paperback book so if you want a
relatively cheap book a less expensive
book this one which just literally came
out as $18 on Amazon it's about this
thick that's fantastic we will have some
things from the handbook of autism which
is more of a reference book we have
about 15 or 20 students in the course
we're going to talk about that we've
talked a little bit about the seminar in
the field placement aspects already
today we're going to have a very
selective introduction this is an
unusual course I think it probably was
the first one in the country on autism
as still as one of the few of its type
I'm going to talk a little bit about
diagnostic concepts history epidemiology
neurobiology dr. Clem's gonna talk some
about Social Development psychological
functioning a bit of the autism program
here at Yale and then we'll have some
time for questions
well if you go on the internet if you go
to Wikipedia which by the way don't ever
sight in a paper at least when you give
to me but it's a handy source of
information if you go to Wikipedia you
will find a PDF file of the first paper
on autism by a man named Lee O'Connor
the O'Connor was the first child
psychiatrist in the country he wrote a
paper in 1943 we're going to talk a lot
more about that we'll have a chance to
talk about Lee O'Connor several times
during the course one question is did
autism exist before Lee O'Connor well
nobody recognized it but it certainly it
must have existed and in fact if you go
back historically this is a picture of
Victor the wild boy in France probably
many so-called feral children children
that people thought were living with the
animals probably were children who had
autism and had been abandoned if you go
back to read some of the reports of
these so-called feral children they have
many of the characteristics we see in
children with autism today in the 1860s
a great British psychiatrist a man named
Maudsley for the first time talked about
children having what he called insanity
at that point in time people had no
knowledge of the kinds of things we
talked about in terms of mental
disorders today they talked about things
like insanity people thought that
children were somehow protected because
they were children and in fact he said
no no I've seen children who are quote
unquote insane this is interesting
because it actually brings a thread
through the work which we'll come back
to which is thinking that is autism how
does it is it a developmental disorder
is it a mental illness is it like
schizophrenia what is it and we'll come
back to that however the term childhood
psychosis which was the more modern term
for childhood insanity and childhood
schizophrenia became synonymous anybody
who was very very disturbed and who
wasn't mentally [ __ ] or
intellectually impaired they said oh
that's childhood psychosis that's
childhood schizophrenia
this continued really in this country
until 1980 Leo Connor was the first
child psychiatrist I mentioned in the
country it was actually a refugee from
Europe fled the Nazis was hired at
Hopkins to bridge the gap between
pediatrics and psychiatry he reported
his paper in 1943 and 11 children who he
said had two things that were or
essential one was autism living in your
own world being cut off from other P
and he had very interesting provocative
and evocative ways of talking about this
on the other side he said the other
thing that was essential was these were
children who had trouble with change how
many people are actually actually ever
actually seen a child or an adult with
autism okay so a lot of you so you know
what he's talking about in terms of
change was he was saying these were kids
who would notice any little deviation
from normal so the parents rearranged
the house that children get very upset
they took a different route to school
the child will get very upset so he
talked about this literally as in
insisting on things being the same way
also however as part of this kind of the
flip side miss in a sense in terms of
insistence on sameness
he said well another part of its
resistance to change he talked about
some of the unusual behavior as we very
commonly see in younger and more
classically autistic children body
rocking hand and finger flicking you say
well how's that resistance to change
how's that insistence on sameness he saw
that as an attempt on the child's part
to maintain sameness in the world
you follow that so it's a little tricky
but in fact it's a whole package this
resistance to change insistence on
sameness thing that includes many of the
unusual movements and mannerisms dr.
Kahn's going to say a little more about
that today we're going to talk a lot
about it later on when we talk about
some of the research but when you think
about it's very interesting as he's
saying these are kids who come into the
world and they don't connect with their
parents and other people like any other
baby will starting from birth on the
other hand even though they're not
living in the world of people they're
very clued into the world of things and
will have a chance to see a little bit
about that later today with dr. Quinn's
talk he thought children were born with
autism he thought it was congenital we
now know that about 20% of the time
children with autism seem to be
reasonably okay and then they seem to
either lose skills they don't keep
developing in the same way so it's not
so clear that it's totally congenital
that being said almost all was by the
time the child is 3 years of age the
parents are worried 90% of the time
parents are worried about the time the
child is to about 60% of the time
parents are worried the child's first
year of life and we'll have a whole talk
we talk about very young children with
autism it's a very active area of
research around here
lastly if you read his paper connor
talked about the work of a man who was
here literally here at yale in the
building right next door man named
Arnold gazelle who was running what
became the Child Study Center back then
gazelle was interested in normal baby
development gazelle was one of the
people charting normal baby development
and he said you know typical babies by
six to eight weeks are starting to smile
back to their parents and for those of
you when you have children you will
discover it's a wonderful location
because for the first time you've been
taking care of this little lump who just
feeds and poops as far as you can tell
and all of a sudden feel my god there's
a person there and very
characteristically happens around six
weeks of age and that's true and Connor
talked about that he said kids with
autism very different I don't seem to go
through that same set of processes and
he was remarkably right about that we'll
talk more about that we now know that
actually from the moment of birth the
typical baby is more interested in the
human face and voice than anything else
in the world and against very different
in autism and here's a quote from Connor
1943 as paper
he says the outstanding pathognomonic
fundamental disorder is the child's
inability to relate themselves in
ordinary ways to people and situations
from the beginning of life there's this
from the start and extreme autistic
aloneness that whenever possible
disregards ignores shuts out anything
that comes into the child from outside
will have a chance to talk about that
that's most true of the youngest
children as kids get older things change
and you'll have a chance to talk about
that now some of the things that Connor
talked about in his first paper some of
it's a wonderful paper but some things
mislead people and these are a couple of
things that exist out there to some
extent as urban myths the first thing
was of the eleven children ten of the
parents either were in who's-who of
america or american men and women of
science remarkably successful people
right this led to the notion especially
in the 50s and 60s that you had to have
very bright parents to have a child with
autism this also led to a somewhat bad
place and then some people said ah maybe
it's because they're so bright they're
not paying enough attention to the child
so people blame to the parents for the
child's trouble
in fact if you think about it Connor is
writing in the late 19th he's seeing
cases the late 1930s early 1940s this is
how many decades before Al Gore invented
the internet remember that this was the
time this is an old audience yeah I've
threatened Lisa I was going to talk
about Trotsky and Emma Goldman today but
she's oh they'll never know about that
interestingly back in the 30s and 40s
there's no great information resource
right like the Internet is today how are
you going to get to the one person the
only child psychiatrists in the country
much less the one person who's
interested in autism you're going to be
well-connected you're going to be
somebody who's working in a university
or college or a very academic a very
successful setting or you can say the
Dean of the medical school the president
of the College of the president
universities say I've got a very unusual
child is there anybody in the country
that's studying unusual children and the
Dean or the president would say geez I
don't know but I'll ask around and we
think that's the reason why there's this
unusual bias for getting very successful
people you see children for autism
everywhere we've now come to appreciate
this was a selection bias children are
born into all social classes I've seen
children from every continent on the
globe except for Antarctica with autism
I'm sure if there were penguins that
were social we would see autistic
penguins but you see in everywhere that
looks remarkably the same now what
differs is how people respond to it
there's a lot of social cultural things
about autism we can talk about in terms
of treatment but how it looks is really
remarkably the same Connor thought
autism was not associated with medical
conditions that led people in the 50s
and 60s say well if you have a medical
problem you can't have autism I'm going
to show you a slide on this in a little
bit
turns out about 20% of strictly
diagnosed children with autism develop
seizures epilepsy hard to imagine right
how can that not be a medical condition
well it took people a while because they
had to follow children over time
he thought children with autism are
going to talk about this next week had
normal levels of cognitive ability why
did he think that some things on IQ
tests puzzles they were great now the
rest of the test they didn't do so well
but he said well if they did this well
the rest of the test their IQ would be
normal which is true but and the but is
they don't they have unusual peaks and
valleys in terms of skills in classical
autism nonverbal skills often are
preserved more verbally mediated things
can be really very very severely
impaired and again we'll have a chance
to talk about that and finally the
schizophrenia business the word autism
had first been used back in the early
1900s to talk about some aspects of
unusual thinking in people schizophrenia
so people who flop things it really
didn't make sense they didn't
communicate very well this confused
people thinking well maybe autism it's
kind of schizophrenia it took people
about 15-20 years to realize that that
was not in fact true and this is sort of
a little summary of what happened over
the years the most important thing to
note was in the 70s people in Great
Britain started looking at children with
autism and looking at children
schizophrenia and said you know this is
not the same kids with autism have
trouble from very early in life
kids with schizophrenia not only do they
look different they hear voices they
look like adults with schizophrenia but
they don't develop their troubles until
much later the classical time to develop
schizophrenia is young adulthood you
sometimes see adolescents very rarely do
you see children it's much less common
than autism and when people then looked
at family histories they discovered no
evidence of increased rates of
schizophrenia in people with autism a
lot of schizophrenia in the families of
children with schizophrenia so people
started making a distinction by the time
there's something called the Diagnostic
and Statistical Manual which is a very
influential psychiatric guidebook to
diagnosis the third edition came out in
1980 and they included autism for the
first time until 1980 you couldn't make
a diagnosis of autism
everybody was thought to have
schizophrenia that was a horrible mess
and model because we couldn't interpret
research we didn't know who was being
studied
so there's a new category of disorder in
DSM V it has changed over time they've
been through various additions this is a
very short summary of what's the current
edition DSM for this came out in 1994
it's the fourth edition you have to have
trouble in the social area in terms of
language and play and also these unusual
behaviors it has a good balance of
sensitivity and specificity it works
very well works well around the world
there was a lot of work that went into
the sm4 dr. Clem who was then I think
probably a postdoc right after that even
even anta dating being a postdoc we
actually had a thousand cases a hundred
Raiders 20-some sites around the world
it was like Ben Hur in the chariot races
and it continues to be for the moment
the approach it's the current definition
of autism that's used predominant in the
United States but also very much around
the world there also it will have a
chance to talk about this next week
other approaches to definition rating
scales checklists and we'll have a
chance to talk about some of these and
again these have their uses their pros
of their cons one of the problems is
what's the gold standard how do you
decide somebody really has autism we
don't have a blood test we don't even
have any physiological things turns out
the so-called gold standard is you get
some really experienced clinicians
together and say yeah you think it'll
kids got autism and so it's a bit of a
you know dog chasing its tail in some
respects we need better in different
approaches and you're going to hear
about some of the work a little bit
today but more when we talk about
infants trying to come up with better
screening methods for finding autism at
very young children I sometimes say my
wife is a pediatrician it's like
somebody came into her that 18 month old
and said I'm worried my child is deaf
and she pulls out a 15 item deaf
question here they said no I know what
it felt some paper and pencil thing I
want a hearing test well we don't have
that for autism but we that's one of the
things we're aiming for we would like
something you'll hear a little bit about
it later today a lot more about it if
you're in the course later on we're
looking for better approaches that are
more robust in terms of screening the
reason that's important for many
children early intervention makes a big
big difference
again when you look into it there's a
lot of other categories that go along
with autism these days this may all
change when dsm-5 comes out we'll have a
chance to talk a little bit about these
I'm going to say just a word about them
very briefly dr. Asperger was working in
1944 he reported a series of boys he was
working by the way in Austria so he was
totally unaware of Leo Conners work the
year before here in the States he wrote
about boys who had horrible social
troubles they couldn't join groups but
they have good cognitive and language
skills unlike children with autism whose
language was often delayed or very
unusual or aberrant they had motor
problems they had very unusual interest
the kid would know all the trains into
another vienna the 615 stops at Leipzig
and Sawyer and the kid would have to
take his parents to the train station to
be sure the 6:15 got in on time and he
made the point that these interest
actually interfere with the child's
learning and he mentioned that there was
often a positive family history but
these were kids whose fathers often were
somewhat socially odd I'll have a chance
to talk about this later on
I actually think dr. Clem's going to
show some drawings to give some examples
in a few minutes but Asperger's
disorders again recognized as an autism
variant it's in that same category the
difference is these are kids who have
good language now they don't have a good
communication they know a lot of words
they often are very fixated on a topic
they can't necessarily carry on a
conversation there's a lot of issues in
terms of thinking about Asperger's some
of the things that Asperger's said the
child talks before he walks words or his
lifeline he emphasized it's different in
autism and although the social deficits
are there the language to some extent is
also there it's interesting and we'll
talk about in terms of implications for
mechanisms and intervention when we
looked at it at DSM for for this big
study in fact we found some differences
for Asperger's which was the reason it
was included at least for the moment
there's someone who's going to be on
campus in a few weeks actually who's
screening the movie Adam which just came
out I think just came out which is about
a young person with Asperger's anyway it
just came out but there's going to be a
the person who produced the movie I
think is going to be here on campus
we'll talk about that when it comes
closer there are a small group of
children who develop normally 2 3 5 6 7
8 years
and then develop something that looks
like autism this is very bad news
unfortunately when you see this most of
these children do very very poorly
people used to not believe parents when
they would say oh my child is perfectly
normal
now with video tapes we can go back and
look you'll see children who are
perfectly fine and we may have a chance
at some point during the course when we
talk about this to see some of these
video tapes child is perfectly normal
and then kaboom it's like somebody pulls
off the lights which the child loses
skills often in multiple areas comes to
look very classically autistic and
typically unfortunately they don't get
things back and finally retz disorder
this was a man named andreas Rhett was
running in 1966 these were girls had
very unusual movements of their hands is
anybody here ever seen a patient with
Rett syndrome okay
very odd hand movements they have
breathing problems movement problems
they have back troubles they are normal
when they are first born and they seem
to lose skills they lose their hand
movements they become very very very
intellectually impaired originally
thought this was some kind of ask autism
in fact people were agreed it didn't
really except at the very beginning it
didn't look like autism at all these
were very characteristic and very
different things we put it in DSM for
because we thought it was officially
interesting that it ought to be studied
and subsequent to the time that got put
in this has been found to be a single
gene disorder there's a very particular
gene called mecp2 which is a regulator
gene which goes kalui
in red syndrome and you can find boys
with this although it's very unusual
it's probably mostly lethal and boys and
again it's very interesting as an
example of something that's relatively
rare but very important because we can
understand the genetic mechanism and
finally there's a funny term pdd-nos
pervasive developmental disorder not
otherwise specified this means kids who
have some features of autism but they
don't meet the full definition
close but no cigar autism
this is a very large group of children
it's probably on the order of 1 and a
hundred and 150 kids but very poorly
studied you can imagine it's hard enough
to get federal money to study autism
think of how much harder it would be to
get something that's not quite autism
they're unlikely to be several subtypes
of this but it's a very interesting area
of work and when you hear those ads on
television about how common autism is
they really are talking about the autism
spectrum especially about PD and OS let
me say a very little bit about
Epidemiology there's a wonderful chapter
which will put on the website for anyone
who's interested by man named Eric from
bone from the handbook of autism he
makes several important points one is
that various various things happen in
terms of look into epidemiology there
are important implications of how big
your study is how small your study is
small studies find higher rates probably
because they do a better job of finding
cases he also points out there have been
changes a definition over time also
there's a problem which is that
sometimes parents would want the autism
label to get services it's a ticket
essentially remember Willy Wonka the
Chocolate Factory is the golden ticket
to get you a lot of services and so
sometimes parents will push to get the
label to get the services
PDD very broadly defined it's probably
about 150 children autism is more like
one eight hundred to a thousand still
not uncommon but not as common as the
broader PDD group and this just shows
you this is data from fond bones chapter
that I've actually graphed out this
shows you the rates of autism over time
starting with the first epidemiological
study but you can see among other things
although things that look like they're
going up in terms of the rate we're also
changing the ways we diagnose autism so
we're looking at a moving target and
particularly DSM for 90/10 which are
essentially exactly the same
we specifically set out to have a system
that worked well for more Abel as well
as for less cognitively able people
which means we're going to pick up kids
that were there they just weren't picked
up before so it's not so clear that the
rate actually is increased even though
it looks like it has and furthermore you
can do something called confidence
intervals around all those same numbers
and then you see that in fact there's a
fair amount of agreement overall in
terms of what people are seeing in terms
of rates
so there's no question that more cases
are being identified but the question is
there a real increase and there are lots
of issues in terms of changing
definition better diagnosis more
awareness and this implication for
services a problem called diagnostic
substitution I mentioned in neurobiology
early on people didn't think there was
much in terms of neurobiology but as
they follow children over time it became
clear two things one was high rates of
seizure disorder epilepsy pretty clearly
a brain based problem right seizures the
other thing was as people started
looking at family members they became
aware of a strong genetic aspect autism
we're going to have a whole talk on that
later in the course this is data
actually from that book that I mentioned
before this is a sample from here in New
Haven of I think several hundred people
with autism this is a sample from Boston
this is data from a normative British
sample five thousand I think normal
typically developing children a normal
normal sample this shows rates of
developing seizures by age so this is
first seizures rates per thousand
and here's less than three three to six
seven to ten obviously once you've
developed a seizure you're going to drop
out of this that excludes children have
febrile seizures if you only have
seizures in relation to fever so this is
really epilepsy and the normal sample
you can see the highest rate less than
three years then it goes down down down
by the time you get to be 1415 less than
1,000 children with autism either in New
Haven or in Boston high rates across the
board including a big group early in
life but then another big group in
adolescence it's not at all uncommon to
hear a child with autism develop
seizures as an adolescent someone let
your age who develop seizures I can tell
you you would be literally worked up the
wazoo because it's very uncommon kids
with autism it's actually not at all
uncommon so this was very convincing to
people thinking this is a brain based
disorder medical conditions with autism
have been a lot of speculations over the
years about people reporting cases of
autism associated with x zmy syndrome z
syndrome the strongest associations are
with some disorders like fragile X and
tuber sclerosis which are strongly
genetic disorders and I mentioned with
epilepsy the problem with many of the
early case reports is there's a bias in
case
reports autism you as a journal editor I
get a paper autism associated with Down
syndrome two papers I might publish that
or I might not in fact I've stopped
publishing case reports for just this
reason but it's more interesting
somebody sends me a paper autism not
seen in two cases of Down syndrome hey
I'm not going to publish that it's not
newsworthy so it's a problem there's a
bias for people to be swayed by these
positive reports of cases so we have to
do more larger epidemiologically based
studies and when you do you find this so
some of the things that people saw early
on people said oh there's an autism
association with congenital rubella kids
with congenital rubella are often blind
and deaf they're very impaired
interestingly if you look at them over
time they look less and less autistic
over time lots of interesting
neurobiological findings we mentioned
the seizure disorder high levels of a
blood transmitter called serotonin so
which owns a transmitter in the brain
that's also found in the stomach and on
the platelets as a group people with
autism have high levels of serotonin
we'll talk some about that when we talk
about psychopharmacology some of the
medications actually work on serotonin
people with autism are more likely to
have unusual reflexes that persist
there's some interesting reflexes that
you see in babies that go away there's
one called for example the visual
rooting reflex I take my pencil of my
reflex hammer I make eye contact and I
go like this typical person looks at me
like I'm a crazy Meshuga person person
with autism not every time and not every
person but a fair number will route it's
like you take a baby and you go the same
thing the baby will route and the idea
is that the babies are programmed to
look for the breast it turns out to the
host of these funny little neurological
signs that you sometimes find in people
with autism there's some work on changes
of the brain actually in terms of the
brain structure especially around some
things called mini columns the
arrangement of the brain in columns the
cortex also something called mirror
neurons you're going to hear about the
fusiform gyrus and faces in just a
second and there's a paper that just
came out from us which has yet to be
replicated but it reports high rates of
placental abnormalities this is a
colleague of ours an ob/gyn who asked us
gee to have any placentas of kids with
autism and they did them to the study
and
they're the Admiralty's or these unusual
what I call trophoblast inclusions that
persist in kids with autism are more
likely to be there otherwise they're
pretty much gone you also see them in
kids with genetic syndromes things like
Triple X syndrome or X X Y syndrome
where they get one too many chromosomes
so lots of areas will have a chance to
talk about this we have a whole talk by
Kevin Pelphrey and autism in the brain
there's a lot of interest in terms of
thinking about brain regions and what
the implications might be for
understanding the social aspects of
autism and genetics if you look pearly
on there was an impression of no
genetics to autism but obviously people
with autism weren't so commonly
reproducing at that time the outcome was
poor many people with autism ended up in
institutional settings as people started
to look and the first study was by
rudder and Folsom in the late 70s
identical twins versus fraternal
same-sex fraternal twins identical twins
are always going to be same-sex right
because they're identical but are being
oh they're not identical fraternal twins
could be a brother-sister they exclude
those because there's a gender
difference in autism we haven't talked
about but well which is that girls when
they get autism tend to be much more
severely affected boys only anything no
much more likely to get autism which is
something that's interesting thinking
about the neurobiology if you look and
this is all the twin studies lumped
together again we're going to have a
whole talk of genetics about 60% of the
time identical twins will have pretty
strictly diagnosed autism if one kid has
autism the other will if you start to
expand your definition a bit you get up
to 90% that's not 100% that's awfully
high and here are the data on the
fraternal twins same-sex so there
clearly is a very strong genetic aspect
the complexity as you'll hear is that
probably there are multiple genes
involved and people have speculated
based on mathematical models somewhere
between four to twenty maybe even more
the interesting thing is you'll hear
when we have state comes to talk is
we're actually close to being able to
find some genes there are some genes out
there that have been identified
once we absolutely do have some genes
they'll be fantastic because we can come
up with animal models we can understand
how the genes are expressed in the brain
environmental causes in autism this is
an area of tremendous interest
especially to the lay public and the
media it's one of those places where
there's a lot of smoke and not so much
fire interestingly enough animal models
have been attempted it's difficult it's
difficult most of the animal studies
have been done to date involve lesion
studies now whatever else is true it's
not as if somebody's coming along and
lesioning the brain of children with
autism and so it's a it's a different
kind of time course it's a different
developmental thing and as you hear when
we talk about some of the things with
babies there's good reason to think that
one of the things that's so difficult
about autism it's that early lack of
social interest then gets entrained in a
lot of other aspects of development it
has a lot of implications for learning
identification of genes clearly will
help because we'll come up with much
better models immunizations and autism
we're actually having Grand Rounds in a
couple of weeks with a man who's written
a wonderful book called false prophets
on this whole topic of immunizations and
autism is a tremendous amount of
evidence that says immunizations do not
cause autism immunizations prevent
illness so we who are not immunized i
from preventable illness but there's
again a tremendous amount of
misinformation out there people have
looked at other things like heavy metals
mercury arsenic lead drugs and other
toxins in fact the data are pretty
limited people also have looked at
cluster cases you know Brook Township
New Jersey it's a funny business I had
the experience a few years ago of having
someone from one of the papers and
Hartford call me and ask me about the
outbreak of autism in Guilford
Connecticut and I laughed at the guy he
said why are you laughing I said that's
the town I tell anybody who's coming to
Yale they want to have a live in a good
town with a good School District I say
ogle of Guilford so I was actually
referring people with autism to Guilford
right so it's a it's a funny business
and again on balance the data for
environmental causes is not horribly
strong there's a paper that will show up
on the reading list by wing and potter
that summarizes all this outcome
research very briefly as time has gone
on kids are doing better with early
intervention we're going to talk about
outcome and I think two weeks we have
more people who are talking people have
higher
of intellectual ability kids are now
going to college there's a whole set of
books out there now for kids going to
college I mentioned the chapel Haven
program is for kids we're doing so well
if they can almost make it independently
in college and they just need a little
push to help them get those life skills
up to the point where they can actually
go and do it often the academic parts
not so challenging it's the social and
the unstructured part that is there are
problems that do remain it's difficult
in terms of understanding the cure
you'll find a lot of people who claim oh
my child was cured of autism over the
years seeing thousands upon thousands of
children probably I've seen five that if
I met the child I wouldn't necessarily
know that they had autism but that's
five out of so probably somewhere over
seven and 10,000 so I remember those now
it's not to say people don't do a lot
better but often there's some residual
problems which is not surprising this is
a very serious problem again and we'll
talk about what normal means and what
cure is treatment there's a very good
report we're going to talk about in two
weeks two weeks on treating children
with autism for the National Research
Council
it looks at all the programs around the
country that have empirical data to show
they work it's about ten of these
programs they're wonderful programs they
have some differences but many things in
common they all focus on structure
intensive intervention they have some
things going for them in terms of
working on the kinds of things
early intervention language
communication joint attention we'll have
a chance to talk about that they do make
the point in this report that not every
child gets better some kids even despite
good programs don't do so well and we
need to understand more about that as a
group children are doing better and
better and better well also have a
chance later on we'll talk about drug
treatments drug treatments don't cure
autism but they can help with some of
the symptoms and sometimes that actually
helps the child participate in program